[Music]
tensions between the us and china have
been steadily escalating
as they spar on everything from
democracy in hong kong
to the data security of tick tock
[Music]
but there's one place where a military
battle between the superpowers is most
likely to happen
the south china sea what started as a
territorial dispute over rocks and reefs
grew into clashes over fishing and
natural resources
now the south china sea is home to
escalating war games
between two of the world's largest
militaries
i think we're getting to a point now
where confrontation
is more likely recent tensions have
threatened to boil over
it used to be in the old days that the
americans were clearly the
superpower they could sail where they
wanted and nobody else could do anything
about it whereas now i think the chinese
are starting to think that maybe they
have
the military power the weapons that
could actually threaten the americans
as joe biden comes into office this is
an issue that's not going to get
any easier to solve because china sees
it as part of its very core strategic
interest to control that territory
that's not going to change whoever is in
the white house we're at a kind of
dangerous
phase at the moment and looks set to
continue
so how did an east asian dispute over a
group of small islands
become a significant flashpoint for u.s
china relations
[Music]
the south china sea encompasses 1.4
million square miles
making it almost one and a half times
bigger than the mediterranean sea
it's a key commercial gateway that sees
one third of the world's maritime
shipping pass through it every year
accounting for more than three trillion
dollars in trade
beneath the surface the maritime life is
vital to the diets and economies of the
surrounding nations
around 12 percent of the global fish
catch comes from these waters
which also hosts more than half of the
world's fishing vessels
even further down beneath the seabed is
the promise of natural gas and crude oil
reserves
the exact amount is disputed with both
the u.s and china giving vastly
different estimates
the u.s estimates that the sea holds
about 190 trillion cubic feet of natural
gas
and 11 billion barrels of oil
south china sea it's a strategic
crossroads really it links
on one side the pacific and the other
side the indian ocean and then north to
china and south to australia
huge amounts of world trade go through
huge amounts of
oil most of the things that we you know
we
buy in the shops that come out of china
japan taiwan all travel through the
south china sea
for decades china and neighbouring
southeast asian nations
have disputed territorial claims within
the area
largely centered around two groups of
islands the spratly islands in the south
and the paracel islands in the north
it's a point of contention because these
are two kinds of disputes there are
disputes about the islands who owns them
but they overlap
with disputes about what you can do in
the sea
whose rules apply and they also overlap
with this
great power competition between china
and the us
so it's this intersection of these three
layers of disputes that's what makes the
the situation so dangerous
brunei malaysia the philippines taiwan
and vietnam all have claims in the
region but it's china's claims that are
the most contentious
china claimed more than 80 of the south
china sea
referring to a map from 1947 that shows
a u-shaped line looping down to a point
about 1
100 miles or 1800 kilometers south of
its heinen island
china's claim in the south china sea
emerged between 1907 and 1947 in those
40 years
and it really emerged in the context of
china
struggling against foreign powers in the
first half of the 20th century
against japan and then later against
france and then against
japan again during the second world war
it became an emotional question it
became a time when china wanted to stand
up against the world
and one way of doing that was by staking
a claim to territory
but beijing didn't start actively
asserting this claim until later in the
20th century
it's really when oil gets discovered
in certain parts of south china sea in
the late 1960s early 1970s that's when
it starts to heat up a bit more
and you start to see more of the islands
being occupied philippines moves in in
the 70s
the vietnamese also do the same thing
and then the malaysians get in the game
the chinese government doesn't make its
first occupations
actually physically you know planting
the flag in the spratly islands until
1988 so
they come very late to the game at that
point in the years that followed
nations jostled among themselves for
control of the islands
but since the mid-1990s the occupation
of most parts of the spratly and paracel
islands
hadn't changed significantly but as
china's position on the world stage grew
so too did their activity in the region
in the chinese telling
of of how this spat began
china says you know back in the early
2000s uh
china and the southeast asian nations
who also have claims there
got along fine and what really sparked
off kicked off
the conflict was when during the early
days of the obama
administration they had this uh pivot to
asia
and so when the us did this pivot to
asia
it sort of encouraged a lot of the
southeast asian nations to start
exerting their claims in the south china
sea to start building on islands that
they had occupied
and so then china by beijing's telling
felt compelled to do the same and to do
it
uh to a greater degree i think there
have been
two major changing points in in recent
years so there's the 2008 financial
crisis when the american economy goes
into a nosedive
you have the same time you have the
beijing olympics when china suddenly
appears on the world stage
and you get a new confidence in china
that maybe their way is superior to the
american way of running the world and i
think that then leads into
the selection of president xi in
2012 by the communist party as their
party leader
china's once in a decade transition of
power was completed earlier today
xi jinping head of the chinese communist
party has just been elected president of
china in a near unanimous vote
before she becomes a party leader in
2012
you have you noticed in the south china
sea different bits of the
the state you know the the coast guard
the the navy
the fishing protection the um the police
whatever
all following different policies from
2013 onwards once she's in power you see
much more centralized control and that's
in 2013 when you start to see china
building these massive artificial
islands in the spratly islands
with huge military bases on
we continue our look this morning on
what china does not want you to see the
united states says the superpower is
reclaiming land
in the south china sea china has begun
this campaign of building islands in
south china sea taking reefs and rocks
and
building on top of that with sand and
filling in the water and
on top of that land they've built uh
airstrips
they've put missiles in they've put in
installments where military personnel
can be there full time
beijing transformed the disputed reefs
and rocks by reclaiming 670 acres of
land from the sea
to create islands with administrative
buildings hospitals and sport complexes
there's also runways that can land
fighter jets and are equipped with
defensive systems
radar antennae and radio systems which
are intended to monitor the area around
them
china's use of the islands in this way
prevents other countries developing
resources
and that directly breaches the united
nations convention on the law of the sea
also known as unklos
anklos was established in 1982 and it
states that a country can have a
territorial zone of 12 nautical miles
off its coast
a further 12 nautical miles where it has
limited controls
and an exclusive economic zone of 200
nautical miles
china argues that the paracel and
spratly islands are part of its
territory
and therefore they own anything within
those exclusive economic zones
be it fish or natural resources and it's
been enforcing this in increasingly
hostile ways
china's general military philosophy is
something called
active defense and the idea is to appear
to be non-threatening and to be
defensive
but to create situations where you lure
the opponent into making a move which
then allows you to respond in
force and in
leave fully for you well therefore
the possibility for all the consequences
so what it's doing now is using these
islands as a means of
uh projecting power so it's successfully
intimidated vietnam and stopped it
developing its offshore
oil and gas reserves it's done the same
thing to the philippines
it's tried to do the same thing with
malaysia but with less success
[ __ ] effect has established a kind
of
a block on the other countries
developing their maritime resources i
suppose the next thing that might happen
will be that then china might
try and use its force to develop
resources which doesn't have any claim
to under the u.n convention
or the sea in 2016 an international
tribunal in the hague
ruled that the paracel and spratleys
were rocks rather than islands
and therefore would not get the benefits
of eez
the ruling also stated that there was no
legal basis for china's claims and what
that meant was that
suddenly the value of the disputed
islands became much
less in theory because it meant you
couldn't claim
huge amounts of resources oil and gas
and fish from around them
however china has refused to recognize
this ruling
and the reason is obvious is that it
actually
diminishes the value of these disputed
islands
and makes the the case for the
surrounding countries vietnam malaysia
philippines brunei
much much stronger for the resources for
the oil and the gas and the fish
diplomats in china and asean countries
have turned their attention to an
earlier legally binding document in the
hope of a resolution
the asean nations and china said to have
reached an agreement to begin
negotiations on a code of conduct in the
south china sea
unfortunately the long-term outlook is
not good the fact is that you have
a negotiation process between asean and
china
that is not really going very well
they're trying to establish
a code of conduct that would set some
parameters for how business is conducted
in south china sea
at the same time however they don't
actually address the dispute
at all so no dispute resolution
mechanisms are really being negotiated
seriously at this time
what's perhaps more concerning is the
ever-evolving
china u.s competition dynamic which is
becoming more aggressive in nature
the u.s is response in the south china
sea has been mainly
driven uh from its sort of overall
strategic interests
because the south china sea connects
america's west coast
from california to the indian ocean and
to the middle east and so they said it's
a vital
strategic corridor for them you know for
civilian shipping but also military
shipping to go through
during the obama administration uh the
issue was very contentious already
and so when trump came in what really
happened was not that the
the conflict arose but the way that the
u.s government began to pursue
its strategy became much more aggressive
became much more proactive and
abrasive that's why the situation in the
south china sea has become much more
dangerous
a u.s presence has been increasing in
the region since 2012.
over the years administrations have
weighed in on arguments over resources
but haven't taken sides in the
territorial disputes
until now beijing doesn't respect the
fundamental democratic values
or those enshrined in the asean charter
previous years
we've seen a lot of positive language
from
regional partners who wish to make room
for china as a global
superpower but china's coming a little
hard
the u.s has issued one of its strongest
warnings against
china over beijing's illegal territorial
claims
in the south china sea it's not china's
maritime empire
the united states is prepared to do the
things
necessary to assist them in protecting
their valid legal claims
[Music]
expansion of the chinese navy has become
one of the latest concerns for u.s and
asean nations
beijing's anti-ship ballistic missiles
are also known as carrier killers
a department of defense report suggests
that china may be the first ever to
attach this category of weapon to a
warship
there's a good reason to think that a
lot of china's activities in the
south china sea in terms of building up
its bases are done
with a possible invasion of taiwan in
mind
they're thinking if there was ever an
invasion an attempt to forcibly
you know bring taiwan into the people's
republic of china
that the united states would try and
defend taiwan and having these islands
there with missiles already on them and
runways and so forth would be a way of
keeping the americans at bay it's also i
think part of
trying to create a a bastion a hiding
place for their
ballistic missile submarines there and a
way of just keeping the americans away
from their southern coast
both china and the us regard the south
china sea as pretty
crucial to their overall strategic
interests which means they're going to
struggle hard
the escalation of military activities in
the south china sea
even in the midst of a pandemic has many
onlookers concerned
a war of words on twitter and state tv
has transformed into warships and
military drills
that could be the start of a new cold
war
in the final waning days of the trump
administration
you've seen a slew of measures taken and
i think a lot of those measures
have been taken to try and prevent joe
biden's administration from coming in
and undoing a lot of what president
trump had put into place during his time
in office
based on what we've heard from the biden
administration
it does seem that the strategy will be
to work more closely with allies if the
biden administration is able to form a
united front
as it comes to the south china sea i
think two things could happen
uh if it becomes a an alliance against
china i think you will see the chinese
become more aggressive and pushing back
on that
the alternative would be some sort of
more inclusive uh
alliance that wants to welcome china
into the fold and if that is something
that happens i think you can see
a much more benign resolution to the
problem
[Music]
obviously there are a lot of things
going on in the united states i don't
think the south china sea is
particularly high on joe biden's
priority list at the moment
but i think in the future in the next
couple of years that is what will start
to develop
[Applause]
you